When Donald Trump was elected president, British
Euroskeptics rejoiced.
The combination of Brexit and a Republican
administration in Washington were supposed
to usher a new era for the Anglo-American
relationship, which would be no longer held
back by Brussels or by President Obama’s
reserved attitude towards the UK.
They were in for an unpleasant surprise.
Although Theresa May was the first foreign
leader to visit the White House after the
inauguration, it is fair to say that she did
not succeed in building a good relationship
with the US president,
and within days after her visit, a petition against
inviting Donald Trump on a state visit collected
nearly two million signatures.
As the president finally visits the UK on
a more low-key trip, it is also apparent that
the two nations have deep substantive differences.
Whether it is the Iran Deal, trade, or regulation
of tech businesses, the UK finds itself more
aligned with other EU countries than with
the United States.
The question then remains: What, if anything,
is still special about the special relationship?
What do you think about US-UK relations?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.